CELEBRITY STARS WHO STARTED TO
FALL.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH THE NEWS
THAT PUSHED THE MIDTERMS OFF THE
FRONT PAGE: THE RESIGNATION OF
JEFF SESSIONS.
ALL RIGHT.
SESSIONS' DEPARTURE COMES LESS
THAN TWO YEARS AFTER HE ANGERED
TRUMP RECUSING HIMSELF FROM THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
THE PRESIDENT REPEATEDLY
EXPRESSED HIS FRUSTRATION OVER
THAT ORIGINAL DECISION TO
RECUSE.
STEPPING IN AS ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS MATT
WHITAKER.
A FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY FROM IOWA
WHO IS SERVING RIGHT NOW -- OR
WAS, AS SESSIONS' CHIEF OF
STAFF.
TRUMP HAS HAD A VERY STRONG
PERSONAL REPORT WITH WHITAKER
WHO FOR NOW WILL OVERSEE THE
MUELLER PROBE AND THE REST OF
THE DOJ BUSINESS, WHICH
INCLUDES, BY THE WAY, DOJ'S
OTHER FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS
INCLUDING THOSE NEW YORK
PROSECUTORS WHO WERE LOOKING
INTO THE FINANCES OF THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS FORMER AIDES.
FOR WHAT THIS 80 RESIGNATION
COULD MEAN, WE ARE JOINED NOW BY
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY SHOWED THE
GIN OF, WHO IS NOT IN THE STUDI
STUDIO.
FORMER U.S. ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
FOX CONTRIBUTOR ANDREW
McCARTHY AND GEORGE
TERWILLIGER, WHO ACTUALLY BECAME
AN ACTING AG HIMSELF.
JOE, LET'S START WITH YOU.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALREADY CALLING --
[CACKLING]
FOR WHITAKER TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
HE WAS A CONTRIBUTOR, HE MADE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE MUELLER
PROBE.
YOUR REACTION?
SPEAK OF THOSE PREVIOUS COMMENTS
ARE NOT REDUCIBLE COMMENTS.
MR. WHITAKER IS A FINE PERSON.
HE IS COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT.
HE KNOWS ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THIS
PARTICULAR CASE.
I AM DELIGHTED THAT SUPERVISION
OF THIS CASE HAS BEEN TAKEN AWAY
FROM DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROSENSTEIN IN TERMS OF HIS
CONDUCT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING WHAT
THEY ALWAYS DO: WHEN THEY DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING ELSE, THEY JUST
START SCREAMING AND YELLING.
THIS IS AN EMBARRASSMENT TO
THEM, BUT IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE.
MR. WHITAKER IS GOING TO BE JUST
FINE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GO TO YOU
SINCE YOU ARE ACTING AG.
I REMEMBER NOW!
I HAD FORGOTTEN.
SCHUMER SAID THE FOLLOWING.
GIVEN HIS PREVIOUS COMMENTS
ADVOCATING DEFUNDING AND
IMPOSING LIMITATIONS ON THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
MR. WHITAKER SHOULD RECUSE
HIMSELF FOR THE DURATION OF HIS
TIME AS ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL.
JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, I WANT TO PLAY
THIS SOUND BITE FROM MARK
WHITAKER.
THIS WAS FROM CNN AND IT WAS
BACK IN JULY OF 2017.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
WATCH.
>> I CAN SEE A SCENARIO WHERE
JEFF SESSIONS IS REPLACED, A
RECESS APPOINTMENT, AND THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL DOESN'T FIRE
BOB MUELLER AND HE REDUCES THE
BUDGET SO LOW THAT HIS
INVESTIGATION GRINDS TO A HALT.
>> Laura: DIFFERENT LIFE WHEN
HE WAS WORKING FOR A NETWORK.
GROUNDS FOR REFUSAL?
>> NO.
TWO QUICK POINTS, LAURA.
IF EVERY TIME A LAWYER MADE
COMMENTS ABOUT SOME MATTER OF
PUBLIC INTEREST AND LATER GOT
INVOLVED AND WOULD LATER HAVE TO
RECUSE HIMSELF, POOR JOE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO PRACTICE
LAW.
BUT SECONDLY, YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN.
>> I'M DOING JUST FINE.
>> THIS WAS A DIFFERENT TIME, A
DIFFERENT SET OF FACTS.
I'M SURE MATT WILL MAKE HIS
DECISIONS BASED ON WHATEVER
CIRCUMSTANCES HE BECOMES AWARE
OF.
>> Laura: JUST FOR OUR
VIEWERS' EDIFICATION HERE, AS
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL IF YOU
HAVE ALL THE POWERS OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
CORRECT?
YOU SIMPLY HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH
SENATE CONFIRMATION.
IT'S THOUGHT TO BE TEMPORARY.
COULD IT BE INDEFINITE?
>> UNDER THE VACANCIES ACT,
THERE'LL BE SOME LIMITATIONS OF
TIME.
AND MATT CAN'T BE NOMINATED TO
SUCCEED TO HIS OWN POSITION
WHILE HE'S IN THIS POSITION.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
EXCEPTIONS, SUCH AS HE CANNOT
SIGN FISAS.
>> Laura: YOUR FAVORITE, OUT
THE DAY BANGING THE SAME RECUSAL
DRAMA THAT GEORGE WAS JUST
REFERENCING.
LET'S WATCH BRENDAN AND COMPANY.
>> MATT WHITAKER COMES WITH A
LOT OF BAGGAGE.
IT'LL BECOME QUITE EVIDENT IF
HE'LL FULFILL HIS OR
POSSIBILITIES THAT POSITION.
>> Laura: ARE YOU SAYING WITH
HIS COMMENTS ON TELEVISION
SHOULD BE RECUSE OVERSEEING THE
MUELLER PROBE PHASE ON THOSE
COMMENTS?
>> A STRONG CASE GIVEN HIS
PUBLIC ACKNOWLEDGMENT ON THIS
PREJUDICE TO VIEW ON THIS ISSUE
THAT HE SHOULD RECUSE HIMSELF.
>> Laura: AND D?
MORE RECUSAL TALK.
IT'S WHAT THEY PUSHED SESSIONS
INTO DOING.
THERE'S A DEBATE ABOUT THAT.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE RECUSE HIMSELF
BUT HE RUSHED TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
A LOT OF PRESSURE PUT ON HIM AND
HE WILTED UNDER IT, MIND YOU.
IS THERE REALLY LEGITIMATE
GROUNDS HERE FOR A FORMER
COMMENTATOR TO HAVE TO RECUSE
HERE?
>> NO, LAURA.
I LOOK VERY CAREFULLY AT WHAT HE
SAID WHEN HE WAS AT CNN.
I ACTUALLY HAVE A COLUMN UP AT
"NATIONAL REVIEW" TOMORROW.
HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING THAT WAS
IN THE NATURE OF REDUCIBLE
COMMENTARY.
HE DIDN'T MAKE ANY PREJUDGMENTS
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION.
HE DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING TO
DENIGRATE WHAT MUELLER IS UP TO.
WHAT I FIND FASCINATING -- I'M
NOT CASTING DISPERSIONS, I WANT
TO BE CLEAR, ON DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROSENSTEIN'S ETHICS, BUT
I HAVE NOT HEARD ANY OF THESE
GUYS COMPLAINING THAT ROSENSTEIN
IS OVERSEEING THIS
INVESTIGATION, NOTWITHSTANDING
THAT MUELLER IS INVESTIGATING
SUPPOSEDLY TRUMP FOR OBSTRUCTING
THE INVESTIGATION BY FIRING
COMEY, A TRANSACTION IN WHICH
ROSENSTEIN IS A KEY PLAYER.
IF THERE IS ANYBODY IN THIS
EQUATION THAT HAS A SCREAMING
CONFLICT OF INTEREST, IT'S ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
I HAVEN'T HEARD THESE GUYS SAY A
WORD ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: JOEL, I HAVE TO ASK
YOU ON PICKS FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE ALL HAVE A COUPLE OF IDEAS.
WHAT ARE YOUR IDEAS?
>> L, I HAVE, UH, A COUPLE OF
IDEAS I SHARED WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND I WILL NOT SHARE
THEM WITH ANYONE ELSE.
IF I SHARE ANY OF MY IDEAS, I
WILL BE SHARING A CONVERSATION
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: CAN YOU GIVE US A
VOWEL        ?
CAN WE DO WHEEL OF FORTUNE?
FORGET IT.
>> THERE ARE PLENTY OF GREAT
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THAT'S A
UNCHARACTERISTICALLY VAGUE
ANSWER FROM JOE THE EVENT OF
.
THIS IS A FUN CONVERSATION.
>> I AGREE WITH JOE.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
>> Laura: AM I THE ONLY ONE
WHO WILL GIVE THE PRESIDENT ANY
ADVICE -- OTHER THAN ANDY AND
JOE AND GEORGE -- IF HE ASK YOU,
WOULD YOU TAKE?
>> LAURA, I DO NOT NEED TO BE ON
A SIGNATURE LINE.
I'M CONTENT TO NOT BE IN THE
CAPTION UNDER WHERE IT SAYS
"U.S. VERSUS."
LOOK, GEORGE TERWILLIGER AND JOE
DiGENOVA HAVE BEEN ON THE TOP
OF EVERY SINGLE LIST OF THIS
QUESTION EVERY SINGLE TIME I'VE
EVER BEEN ASKED IT.
BOY, COULD THE PRESIDENT EVER DO
A LOT WORSE.
>> Laura: WE GOT TERWILLIGER
ON THE LIST.
I'M TRYING TO HINT AROUND THIS,
ANDY.
YOU GAVE IT AWAY.
YOU HAVE JOE ON THE LIST.
YOU HAVE TERWILLIGER ON THE
LIST.
YES, YOU ARE.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A SUGGESTION.
JUST TO THROW IT OUT THERE, YOU
CAN ALL CRITICIZE AND ATTACK.
IT'S FINE.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A SUGGESTION
OF CHRIS CHRISTIE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF REASONS
WHY CHRISTIE WOULD BE GOOD AND
WE MIGHT HAVE HIM OUT OF ORDER
IF WE HAVE A GRAPHIC.
NUMBER ONE, HE HAS AN 18 YOUR
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY GET ALONG, THEY KNOW EACH
OTHER.
HE HAS ALREADY WALKED THROUGH
THE MEDIA FIRE.
HE KNOWS WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE IN
THE BRIGHT, WHITE SPOTLIGHT OF
THE NEW YORK MEDIA, AND FRANKLY
THE NATIONAL MEDIA.
I THINK TEMPERAMENTALLY HE AND
TRUMP ARE SIMILAR.
THEY GET ALONG AS PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE KIND OF A SIMILAR
STYLE.
THAT'S NOT A DETRIMENT IN THIS
JOB WHATSOEVER.
HE WAS KNOWN AS A TYPE OF NAILS
PROSECUTOR, VERY WELL RESPECTED
BY CAREER PROSECUTORS AT DOJ.
I THINK BRIDGE-GATES -- I DO NOT
THINK ANY OF THAT MATTERS WITH
THE NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS WE
HAVE IN THE SENATE, CHRISTIE
WOULD BE CONFIRMED.
IF THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS IS
THE GUY WE WANT, I THINK CHRIS
CHRISTIE WOULD GET CONFIRMED.
I DON'T THINK IT'S MUCH OF A
PROBLEM.
I DO NOT THINK THAT BEACH
CLOSURE IS GOING TO KNOCK HIM
OUT OF IT, OKAY?
THAT'S MY VIEW.
JOE, GIVE ME SOME THOUGHTS ON
THAT.
KRISTI?
>> CHRIS CHRISTIE WOULD BE FINE.
HE'S EXPERIENCED, HE'S SMART,
HE'S INTELLIGENT.
HE WOULD HAVE THE FULL
CONFIDENCE OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WHICH TO ME
WAS MISSING WITH THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH JEFF SESSIONS.
THE PRESIDENT IS ENTITLED TO
HAVE A FULL-TIME
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> Laura: ANDY McCARTHY,
WHAT ABOUT CHRISTIE?
>> I'VE HAD MY POLICY DOES
AGREEMENTS WITH HIM, BUT NO ONE
CAN QUESTION HIS CREDENTIALS.
I AM WORRIED THE BRIDGE GATES
THING WOULD BE MORE OF A PROBLEM
THAN I THINK YOU ARE
CALCULATING, BECAUSE I THINK
THEY WOULD TRY TO RELITIGATE
THAT WHOLE THING.
>> Laura: REPUBLICANS IN THE
SENATE AREN'T GOING TO
RELITIGATE IT.
IF THE PRESIDENT SAID, I KNOW
HIM, HE'S NOT GOING TO WILT
UNDER PRESSURE, HE'S NOT GOING
TO GO, "RECUSAL, RECUSAL,
RECUSAL" -- HE HAS A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH MUELLER.
HE'S NOT BEEN ON TV SAYING IT'S
A WITCH HUNT.
HE'S BEEN DISPASSIONATE IN HIS
OVERALL ANALYSIS, ANDY >> YET --
NO, LOOK, ALL OF THAT IS TRUE.
I THINK IT WOULD BE MORE OF A
PROBLEM THAN YOU
DO IN TERMS OF THE WAY IT PLAYS
OUT IN A
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
I THINK HE WOULD DO A GOOD JOB.
BY THE WAY, HIS LAWYER IN BRIDGE
GATE WAS CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
>> Laura: THE TANGLED
TENTACLES ALL AROUND.
WE'LL LET YOU GO.
WHAT DO THE REPUBLICANS HAVE IN
STORE IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WITH SUBPOENA
POWER, ALL THESE VERY ANXIOUS
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE BEEN OUT OF
POWER FOR A WHILE, EMOLUMENTS
CLAUSE, BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> IT HAS THE PROMISE OF GETTING
REALLY UGLY.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE IS
GOING, AND THE ADMINISTRATION IN
GENERAL, ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
MAKE SOME VERY HARD DECISIONS
WANT THINGS TO FIGHT, WHEN TO
FIGHT, AND HOW TO FIGHT.
BUT THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
FIGHT.
>> Laura: AGAIN, CHRIS
CHRISTIE IS A FIGHTER.
ANYONE WHO'S SEEN HIS OLD PRESS
CONFERENCES, AMONG THE MOST
ENTERTAINING.
HE'S REALLY SMART.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT SOMEBODY AT THE TOP OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, PARTICULARLY
WITH THESE ISSUES CANNOT BE A
REAL PROSECUTOR NOW.
>> Laura: WHO KNOWS HOW TO DO
IT.
THAT WAS A DEFICIT FOR
JEFF SESSIONS FOR JEFF SESSIONS
I THINK IS A VERY NICE PERSON.
HE'S PHENOMENAL ON SO MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT TRUMP CARES
ABOUT AND WAS GREAT -- I LOVE
WHAT HE'S DOING ON THE MARIJUANA
THING.
I'M WITH THEM ON THAT.
HE IS TEMPERAMENT VERSUS REAL
NUTS AND BOLTS EXPERIENCE IN
THAT REGARD.
>> WELL, AND HE HAD ANOTHER
PROBLEM WHICH IS THE
PRESIDENT INSISTS ON PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COMMAND PRESENCE.
THAT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
WHICH CHRIS CHRISTIE WOULD BRING
TO THE JOB.
WITH ROBERT MUELLER SPENDING
MORE THAN $38 MILLION TO PRODUCE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING BY WAY OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, CHRISTIE
WOULD BE THE PERFECT OVERSEER OF
THAT MONSTROSITY.
>> Laura: BEFORE I LET YOU GO,
ANDY, DOES THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION -- HOW DO YOU SEE
IT DEVELOPING AT THIS POINT WITH
THE CHANGE OF SESSIONS?
>> I THINK IT'S PROBABLY PRETTY
RIGHT.
I THINK MUELLER IS TOWARDS THE
END OF WHAT HE'S DOING ANYWAY.
I THINK YOU WANT A WARTIME
CONSUL
CONSIGLIERE.
DID I PRONOUNCE THAT RIGHT, JOE?
>> YES, YOU DID.
>> Laura: HAVE YOU NEVER
WATCHED "THE GODFATHER?"
FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INSIGHT.
WILL YOU COME BACK?
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> Laura: MUCH BETTER THAN JOE
AND ANDY.